[拍手]
石仏ありがとうございますかなり緊張がほぐれました
うんっ
はいみなさんこんにちは
ここ数年貧困という言葉をたくさん耳にするようになったのではないでしょうか
子どもの貧困
若者の貧困そして高齢者の貧困
誰にでも起こりうる未来の一つに貧困があります
その中でも女性の比率が高いことにも気づきでしょうか
ではなぜ女性の比率が高いのか
その理由の一つに女性が経済力を持つことが少ないというのがあるのかと思います
私はシングルマザーの自立支援をしています
シングルマザー彼女たちは仕事と子育ての両立で悩み
一般家庭の生活貧困ですね貧困率が一般家庭よりも高いという現実の中で
の現実でいますそして一般世帯の平均年収の1/3程度の年収で
日常の生活を置く議員子どもの教育費を考えそして自分の老後の暮らしまでを考え
なければいけません
日本にはそんなシングルマザーのためにたくさんの支援策があります
今日私が皆さんにお伝えしたいことは
国の支援策をに頼らずに自分らしく暮らせるシングルマザーを増やす方法です
国の支援策には児童扶養手当体というものを中心として助成金など毎月いくらカー
いただけるようなそういった形がいくつもあります
大変私たちにとってはありがたい遅延ではありますがこの支援に頼りすぎてしまうと
経済力をつけるという
いうことになかなか行動が進まないという現実もあるんです
例えばですねシングルマザーになった時
35歳だったとしますそして子どもが5歳
児童扶養手当は18歳までもらいます
なのでこの間13年間あります
しかし児童扶養手当をもらうということを考えて仕事を選んだりしてしまうとこの13
年間経済力をつけるという行動になかなかならないという現実があります
例えば35歳の時点で
もちろん支援策を使うのももちろんなんですけども
自立をする経済力をつけるという視点が少しあったらどうなっていたか
このまま48歳を迎えて経済力がないまま48歳迎え子どもが18歳になり児童扶養
手当が終わり
さらに収入が低くなり生活に困っていくシングルマザーが現実に増えています
少し私の話をさせてください
こちらの写真私娘が5人いるんですけど
数年前に娘撮った写真で進めたいともう6年前ですね
こっちなんですけど
孫の後にいるんです
はいでこれはまあ今年撮った写真なんですけども
おかげさまで今間もなくクリスマスが近づく中でどれだけプレゼントをくれと言われる
のか
強い状況ではありますが今はそれにも多少応えられるようになっています
私は子ども5人を連れて離婚をしました
その時家離婚前から住んでいた家新12万の賃貸マンションでクラシー
なんと収入は私15万円程度しかありませんでした
区役所に相談に行き
いったところ生活保護も視野にと言われました
自分ではその解決方法を持っていなかったのでちょっと心が揺れました
ちょっと楽になれるのかな
だけどもどうしても首を縦に振ることはできなくて
そのまま私は区役所を去る中でそれからによと相談を
実は入っていませんその後私は自分の少ない情報の中で仕事を選択し朝から晩まで働く
ということを決めました
しかし子育てと仕事の両立は思った以上に大変でした
長女と杖この年齢差が12歳保育園に預けている時間だけでは足りないので夜は子ども
だけでお留守番をしてもらっていました
長女にはたくさんの負担をかけたと思いますしかしこのときの私にとってそれが悩みに
なるほどの余裕もなかったんです
それでも私の心と体は疲弊して行き
子供たちのことを考えてあげる余裕など全くなかったというのがその時の状況でした
もしこういう時期に
ちょっと悲しい出来事や辛い出来事が重なってしまったら
地蔵虐待につながっていたかもしれない
今だから
考えられるんですけど
今もってもぞーっとします
その後私は幸運にも
子供の成長に合わせて転職を数回することで収入を上げることに成功しました
なのでどうにかクリスマスも乗り越えられそうです
でその私が自立ができた唯一のたった一つです本当に理由は
収入を上げることを優先に考えたことが私が経済的自立ができた限りした
自立には企業とのつながりが不可欠です
なぜならば
収入を上げるということが絶対的に必要だからです
企業の2013年に日本シングルまだ支援協会を私は立ち上げました
その時点から今日まで500社以上の企業からの問い合わせがあります
その多くがシングルマザーを雇用したいというものなんです
れシングルマザーの雇用で企業と関わっている間に企業側から今ゆる社員の今で言う
女性社員のことも相談にさせてくれないかな
などというような意見もたくさんもらえになりました
そこで思ったんですね
シングルマザーの自立支援に対して一生懸命
形を構築してきたんですが気がついたら女性が働きやすい職場づくりというものにも
つながっていたんだなというところをに感じました
で実際今どこでも企業は人材不足です
先ほど言いましたように500社ほどの以上の a
問い合わせが私たちの会社の支援協会にはあるんですけれども
それは今シングルマザーの雇用というのが注目をされているということにつながります
またいろいろな企業の中で女性活躍推進というのを進んでいるかと思います
ただあまり上手くいっているという話は大企業ぐらいしか聴かないんじゃないかなと
もう割れ感じられるれる方もいらっしゃると思うんですけどもええこれはじゃあなぜか
というと
基本的に私たちは今普段感じることでもあるんですが
企業側の女性罹患への低さ
これが原因だと感じます今世の中は社会は男性社会です
男性のモチベそんなあげ方ですべてが動き
子育てというものを1ミリも考えない中でお仕事が与えられている
その中で女性は自信を失っていっているというような現状があります
でもう一方でシングルマザーの課題について考えてみたいと思います
彼女たちはたくさんの相談を受けている中でシングルマザーの課題は孤独と経済だと
感じています
で最初に孤独を埋めることで仲間のコミュニティによって孤独を埋めることによって
情報収集力が高まるんですね
仲間がいるのでそれによって
経済の解決は行ってきていくんだなというのもわかるようになりました
そしてまたどうしても自信を失ってしまうという現状が今の社会に一人で飛び込んで
しまうといろんなことが起こってしまうという現状がありますマインドの調整
ただし君の中に放り出しただけで放り投げただけでは気持ちが出来上がっていない
恐怖心堺への恐怖心自分の自信のなさというものを女性が持っているとそこで私たちは
自立支援プログラムというのオリジナルで作りました
多くのシングルマザーの方が私たちのところに来た時に自信を失っています私は何も
できない
社会で通用できない
自信を失っている方に対してまず
自信を持っていたら持ってもらう実したいなーっていう気持ちになってもらうという
ことを最初にやります
の後にどうすれば事実をできるかを一緒に考えていきます
今度考えたことを行動に移すというところまでを寄り添っていきますそして自立確実と
なります
このあたりでは年収が高い生井というよりはマインドに反しての自立です
そして自信を持ってこの後企業に紹介してあげることができるようになります
物事をその中でシングルマザーの方の今の状況というのを見極めることも大切だという
ことが分かりました
物事を前向きに考えることをとらえることができるのか
そしてやはり私もそうでしたけど経済力をつけると収入を上げるということを優先順位
の上位に置くことができているか
その中で4つの分類にママたちを4つの部分にしています
キャリアママ
わくわくまましっかりまま
そしてモヤモヤままと分類をしてそのどれに当てはまるかによってそれぞれの人に合っ
た支援をしていきますキャリアママの場合はもうすぐにマインドは頭と思っているので
すぐに事実への行動へと寄り添っていきます
わくわくままの場合この人たちを楽しませるということでさらにぼてんしゃるをあげる
んです
周りの草がどれだけ楽しませてあげることができるかで活躍の仕方が変わります
しっかりままの場合は少し真面目に考えすぎて少しあの悩みが多くなったりすることが
あるのでできていることを教えてあげる
自分を褒めるということを押し伝えるという形で寄り添います
モヤモヤままの場合もしかしたら自立をするのは難しいかもしれません
そういう場合は彼女がどんなことに幸福感を感じているのかを一緒に考えて寄り添って
いくという形を取りますここまでシングルマザー
側の課題と企業の課題の両面を見てきました
シングルマザーが自分らしく生きていくためには新この両方のへのアプローチが必要に
なります
まずシングルマザーの課題として教育をしていきますマインドアップの教育ですね
寄り添うという中で教育を提供していきます
そして次に企業に就職するときなどは
見学に一緒に行き面接にも投稿するとそういった行動の中から自分では選択をしない
ようなこと
まで選択をしていけるようになるんです今まで選ばなかった仕事をやるようになります
今営業職事務職から営業職への転職を応援しているんですね
なぜかというと事務職では子供を大学に行かせるほどの収入になることがほぼ難しいん
です
なので営業職に推奨してるんですが多くの人がやはり営業職やったことがないって自信
がないっていう中で私たちを声を聞きます
どんな生活を望んでいるのとそうすると皆さんお子さんの話をします
子供が好きなことをやらせてあげたい
大学に通わせたいそうだよね今の働き方でそれはかなうと思う
すよねーと自分の選択肢を考え直すというきっかけになっています
そして企業側ですが a
まず女性に対してのアプローチの方法というのを伝えています
そして教育を促した女性シングルマザーを紹介しています
またここからがなかなか企業さんも素晴らしいなと思うんですが
一緒にこの取り組みをしているのを横で見ている中で企業さんもどんどんシングル
マザー側女性側に何かをしてあげようって変わってくるんです
またお母さんが
挑戦をし始めると一番最初にそれに気づくのはお子さんなんです
こういった活動の中で子どもにおかあさん
おかあさん楽しそうだねって言われましたっていう嘘が本当に多くてそれは私たちも
すごく嬉しいなと感じているところです
最後になりますが
シングルマザーの自立支援をというところで事実をする喜びを
の中で輝いていくシングルマザーの方は私たちをたくさん見ています
事実ができる人には事実の方法を伝えて
寄り添います
で福祉の支援ばかりを受ける人が増えていたら本当に福祉の支援が必要な人に届かない
可能性があるんです
今
福祉のあ今日本の財政は決して豊かではないということを私たちは知る必要があります
弱者だと言われている人たちに対して守るだけではなくてその人たちにポテンシャルを
その人たちのポテンシャルを信じて寄り添うこと
自分を信じ他人を理解する
そして多様化の世界を皆で受け入れていくことによって
一人一人が幸福感を感じることを遺憾た幸福感を感じながら暮らしていくことができる
でしょう
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]